[Music]  dare turn your back on Elizabeth of  England I am Queen I will not be treated  in this manner we were certified insane  she's been brought up to believe it's  God's will strips Maine bear and your  dagger try me  no one really knows what it's like to be  creep everyone about to start majesty  kakou I'm not your Elizabeth you were  the Queen your husband's brother's wife  and would it were not so you are safe  you've been plucked since I saw her last  and not like you women can be the match  of men  we concede men do have some value so we  accept them as equal  you must love somebody else I forgive  you I try to love others  what others  [Music]  [Applause]  [Laughter]  surprise what is it a mango your majesty  it's off Samri this mango is off  [Music]  [Music]